الدويري الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجي
مرحبا بك سيد فايز يعني الى جانب هذا
القصف وما اعلنه حاكم سباس سبول عن طائرات
مسيره اوكرانيه استهدفت شبه جزيره القرم
يبقى الوضع في باخموت ربما هو الاسخن
والاكثر حضورا ميدانيا الى اي مدى بامكان
السلطات السلطات العسكريه الروسيه قطع
الامداد عن القوات الاوكرانيه في بخموت
كما اعلنت او كما تطمح خلال الايام
المقبله
يعني دعني ابدا بما تحدث به قائد مجموعه
فاغنر عندما اشار الى ان السيطره على
باخمت لا يمكن ان تحدث بين عشيه بما معناه
بين عشيه وضحاها وقد تكون في شهر اذار او
شهر
اربعه شهر نيسان اي بمعنى اخر انا لا تزال
هذه المدينه القوات الموجوده فيها قادره
على الاستمرار في القتال واطلق عليها
معركه مفرمه اللحم لكن هناك تغيرات جوهريه
افضت الى هذا الواقع واهم هذه التغيرات
الان طبيعه المعارك اختلفت عن ما قبل
معارك باق موت او الهجومون الهجوم الاخير
على سوليدار اصبح الان هناك مزج او دعم
الجيش الروسي النظامي بقوات فاجنر التي
تقاتل بطريقه مختلفه بدا هناك
تحديث في اطار طبيعه اداره المعركه حيث
بدات تعتمد على الموجات البشريه المتلاحقه
بغض النظر عن الخسائر واخر رقم لقبل ثلاث
ايام في يوم واحد ما يعادل 140 قتيل روسي
اذا كانت المعلومات دقيقه
وموثقه الامر الثالث وهو عمليه استخدام ما
يطلق عليه السدود الناري المفرطه من اجل
ترويض هذه المناطق ومحاوله السيطره عليها
والتي قد توظف لاحقا بما يسمى القصف
التمهيدي لهجوم اوسع نطاقا ولكن النقطه
الفارقه من قراءه للخارطه ومجريات المعركه
ان معركه باكموت التي يتم تركيز الاضواء
عليها هناك وراء الاكمه ما هو اخطر منها
وعندما ننظر الى منطقه
كريمينا ايزيوم لمان والى الشمال منها الى
خار كيف اعتقد ان المدقق والمراقب وعلى
العسكري ان ينظر بكلا العينين الى تلك
المنطقه لان تلك المنطقه قد تكون
تداعياتها اكبر من معركه
شكرا جزيلا لك من عمنا لواء فايز دويري
الخبير العسكريه والاستراتيجيه